so massive protests have now broken out
in Iran president Trump is doing the
right thing Democrats are not doing the
right thing and CNN turns to pot on New
Year's Eve yes really we're back it's a
new year I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
so 2017 wasn't as bad as people thought
it was gonna be everybody's all worried
that the world was gonna end in
everything and it didn't everything was
pretty much okay yeah there was turmoil
yes it has its ups and downs like the
last Jedi but did it but was it was it
okay in the end yeah it was okay in the
end sort of like the last Jedi and sort
of not so we will get to all of the
late-breaking news that happened over
the break most of it coming from abroad
we will get to all of the media's insane
coverage of the situation in Iran we'll
also get to some guy named Logan Paul
who I hadn't heard of until the last
five minutes and him walking into the
Japanese suicide for us there's lots to
talk about but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Birch gold
so right now the stock market is doing
really well and the economy is very
healthy there are a lot of economists
however who are worried about some sort
of stock market plunge the possibility
of a stock market kind of implosion or
the very least but if a drawback they're
worried about the possibilities of
inflation even though the Fed has been
cutting back on some of the interest
rates in any case if you are concerned
about any of these situations and you
should be because they happen then you
should really be looking at diversifying
your portfolio one of the ways you do
that is you buy some precious metals and
the people you talk to are my friends
over at Birch gold Birch gold group has
a long-standing track record of
continued success thousands of satisfied
clients countless five-star reviews and
a plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau contact my friends over at Birch
gold group now to request a free
information kit on physical precious
metals to comprehensive 16-page kit and
it reveals how gold and silver can
protect your savings and how you can
legally move your IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA I'm not somebody believes you
take all your money and put it in
precious metals but you certainly should
put some of it in precious metals as I
have talked to my friends over at Birch
gold to ask all your questions and then
buy yourself some precious metals
birchgold.com / bond that is
birchgold.com
/ then oh right so over the last week
and a half well we have been gone
massive protests have broken out in Iran
those protests are ongoing the they've
resulted in the death of apparently 15
people the Iranian Revolutionary Guard
is shooting people in the streets they
are now arresting a hundreds of
dissidents the the protests apparently
started originally when people who did
not like Hassan rouhani who is the the
radical leader of the the political arm
of the ayatollahs in Iran then like Hani
because the economy has been bad and
they started protesting him just like
all the other protests in the Muslim
world that took place during the Arab
Spring the original purpose of the
protest very often has nothing to do
with where the protest goes right the
original protests against Hosni Mubarak
in Egypt ended up with the Muslim
Brotherhood taking power in this
particular case it looks like there was
some radical fundamentalist who started
some of the protests and then the
moderates turned out in force and now
you have thousands of people marching
through the streets of Iran it's so bad
over there that the Iranian government
has shut down Twitter they've shut down
Facebook they've shut down social media
I don't know whether these companies by
the way are engaging in that process
whether they're allowing Iran to do that
or not if they are they should stop they
should stop allowing Iran to do so
immediately in any case the Europeans
have been utterly silent as the
Europeans often are when it comes to
moral atrocities throughout history
president Trump however has not been
silent President Trump has been speaking
out and this is driving the left up a
wall it's driving the left up wall for
two reasons one President Obama was
awful on the issue of Iranian freedom he
routinely quashed any sort of capacity
for Iranian Revolution and resistance
during 2009 you recall a woman named
Neda was shot to death on camera was a
major worldwide story and she was a
protester President Obama really did
nothing about it in fact we have a clip
of President Obama in 2009 while he's
protesting how Iran is treating
dissonance he also said we respect
around sovereignty basically they can do
what they want we're not gonna do
anything about it I've made it clear
that the United States respects the
sovereignty of the Islamic Republic of
Iran and is not interfering with Iran's
affairs but we must also bear witness to
the courage and the dignity of the
Iranian people and to a remarkable
opening within Iranian society that
remarkable opening came to nothing
because president because President
Obama did nothing to foster it in fact
at the time when President Obama was
basically cow telling to the Iranians he
was doing so because he was trying to
force forward and that Iranian nuclear
deal that was just a disaster area for
all involved maximized Iran's power ship
pallets of cash to Iran made Iran a
regional power allowed them essentially
to take over Iraq allowed them to prop
up Bashar Assad in Syria allowed them to
extend their influence into Lebanon and
in Yemen that a lot of that had to do
with President Obama deciding that he
was going to turn the radical government
Iran into some sort of beacon of power
in the region that was Obama's decision
and he threw dissidents under the bus he
allowed them to die without any sort of
worldwide effect he says that there's
been a remarkable opening in Iranian
society there was no remarkable opening
in Iranian society the media Obama they
pretended that there was some sort of
moderate regime that had taken the
reigns in Tehran that obviously was
untrue as late as five months ago there
were Christians newly converted
Christians in Iran who were sentenced to
ten years in prison but maybe about 11
of them all of them sentenced to years
and years in prison for converting to
Christianity there is no major opening
in Iranian society there has not been
and now people are protesting and
President Trump look at the contrast
between President Trump and President
Obama on this Obama who says we respect
around sovereignty Trump not as
interested in in that routine here as
president Trump's reaction over the
break to what was going on in Iran
oppressive regimes cannot endure forever
and the day will come when the people
will face a choice will they continue
down the path of poverty bloodshed and
terror or will the Iranian people return
to the nation's proud roots as a center
of civilization culture and wealth where
their people can be happy and prosperous
once again and that's of course what
Trump said at the at the United Nations
a few weeks ago but he retweeted that in
the middle of these protests and then he
came out and he basically said I'm happy
to watch the regime fall right so Trump
has not been unclear about his
perspective on this and Trump is 100%
right he has joined in this response by
Benjamin Netanyahu the Prime Minister of
Israel here's what Netanyahu had to say
about the protests in Iran brave
Iranians are pouring into the streets
they seek freedom they seek justice they
seek the basic liberties that have been
denied to them for decades
Iran's cruel regime wastes tens of
billions of dollars spreading hate this
money could have built schools and
hospitals
no wonder mothers and fathers are
marching in the streets the regime is
terrified of them of their
own people that's why they jail students
that's why they ban social media okay
this is when we cross leadership now
it's funny the left likes to proclaim
that President Obama was a world leader
and we're gonna get to the Obama
administration response to all of this
in a second they like to claim that
Obama's world leader and that Trump has
abdicated world leadership Susan Rice
the awful national security adviser for
Obama the lady who used to go on TV and
lie routinely about Benghazi she wrote
an op-ed for the New York Times in which
she accused Trump of abdicating moral
leadership in the world but that's
because the left and the right have two
very different pictures of what moral
leadership constitutes okay the the
Obama administration is the kind of
administration where when Israel had a
guy named Qasem Soleimani who was the
commander of the Kuhns force which is a
branch of the Iranian Revolutionary
Guard a terrorist group Israel had that
guy in the crosshairs they were going to
kill him and President Obama found out
about it and he told the Iranians he
told the Iranians about it because he
was trying to prop up the nuclear deal
at the time right that is world
leadership according to the left world
leadership according to the right is
President Trump saying listen the United
States has an interest in Iranian
freedom we'd be better off if this
terrorist regime were not running that
country and we had instead a moderate
regime yes a moderate Muslim regime in
Iran that would be much better that's
leadership now why does that gap exist
why is it that people on the Left
believe that Obama was a great world
leader and people on the right believe
that Trump is actually exhibiting
leadership here well first of all I'd
like to point out that what Trump is
doing here is very different than what
Trump did on the campaign trail on the
campaign trail Trump was a quasi
isolationist America first seemed like a
slogan that was more from Pat Buchanan
and then it was from Ronald Reagan is he
more like a Charles Lindbergh slogan
than a George W Bush slogan in practice
it turns out that President Trump has
acted a lot more like Ronald Reagan than
he has like Woodrow Wilson or rather
than he has like like a Pat Buchanan or
Charles Lindbergh figure that has been I
think a very positive move but the big
difference between Obama and Trump on
this stuff is how they view universal
values like freedom and liberty
so for Obama the way that he defined
liberty and freedom is he looked to the
Europeans right he called it leading
from behind he basically said you know
there are morally relativistic values
there there's no universal value of
Liberty there's
Universal value of freedom really it's
just what majority decides upon and if
the entire European body says that
freedom in Iran is allowing the regime
to continue to main control maintain
control then we will allow them to do so
because that's freedom
that's Liberty so we'll follow the
majority the majority will tell us what
freedom in Liberty are that was his
version of leadership leadership is
balance the majority Trump's version of
leadership is saying listen I think that
there is a value called freedom I think
there's a value called Liberty and I
think that America is a promulgator of
those forces in the world I think that
America makes the world a better place
and I think that so long as we can
pursue policies that make America
stronger that benefit America first but
America should be benefited because it
is good and because it is great and
because it is true to those universal
values that are not decided by majority
vote in the halls of power in Europe
then we should stand by the Iranian
people and that's the difference and
it's a major difference and it's much
more akin to George Washington than
anything that Obama said now if you look
at what George Washington said about
foreign policy he said that we shouldn't
get caught up in entangling alliances
what he meant by that was he said the
big danger to the United States the big
danger to the United States because we
will be a world power this is what he
said in his farewell address the big
danger to us will be entangling
alliances did he mean that we can't have
alliances at all no what he meant was
that America has to follow her own star
that American values are not necessarily
going to be the values of Europe and we
can't sign permanent agreements with
nations on the basis of values that can
change over time and we can't see
ourselves seduced away from universal
values that are worthwhile we can't be
seduced away from those values simply
because the Europeans would like us to
be I think that is what Trump is saying
here and I think Trump is doing the
right thing here pretty clearly now in a
second we're gonna discuss exactly what
it is that the left is responding to
because the left's response to Trump has
been truly astonishing right these are
all the people who say that Trump was
not going to react well to to chaos in
the world that Trump was going to be a
danger to the world that Obama was some
sort of great Halcyon of freedom and
liberty and world leadership but the
response from the Obama administration
figures from the media too has just been
astonishingly garbage I mean really
really quite terrible so here is what
Samantha power tweeted so Samantha power
and tweeted this out she's the former UN
Ambassador under President Obama
as Sara Huckabee Sanders the press hyper
surfer trumpet tweeted out the days of
America looking the other way from the
Iranian regime's oppression are over
America stands with the Iranian people
great Samantha power who wrote a book on
genocide and then presided over part of
the administration that actively sought
to allow Bashar Assad to participate in
genocide Samantha power tweeted out we
stand with the Iranian people so much
that we won't let them come here as
she's slapping from so we're in the
middle of a of a fight with the Iranian
government that is repressing its own
people and Samantha power takes time out
to bash Trump because Trump has a travel
ban against people traveling from Iran
now I think what Samantha power misses
here a couple things one Samantha power
has no leg to stand on whatsoever as in
no leg to stand on whatsoever when it
comes to speaking about the Middle East
she was participant in a regime in
astray ssin that upheld and strengthened
the worst terror regime on planet Earth
and Iran but beyond that the reason that
so many Iranians want to flee the
country is in part because they were
propped up by the Obama administration
if the Iranians actually had a good
government they wouldn't need to come
here that's the whole point this idea
that we have to let all of the Iranians
in not vetted we have to let any Iranian
and who wants to come in not vetted by
the government because we can't trust
the government over there or we have to
shut up about what's going on in Iran no
the whole point is we want to change the
government over there so they don't have
to come over here that's the entire
point it's not just a man to power Ben
Rhodes who is just a despicable human
being Ben Rhodes is of course the former
deputy national security adviser and in
special counsel to the President on
foreign policy he was a fiction writer
who wrote short stories unpublished
short stories from a Brooklyn apartment
before he was elevated to foreign policy
specialty under the Obama administration
you'll recall the Ben Rhodes is the same
guy who lied repeatedly to the American
people the Obama administration had a
had a ridiculous story that they used to
push the nuclear deal the ridiculous
story that they used to push the nuclear
deal was that the Iranian regime had now
become more moderate than Hassan rouhani
the new leader after Mahmoud Ahmadinejad
he was actually a new moderate type and
we had an opening we had a gap we were
finally gonna be able to do something
moderate with the Iranians and it was
Rhodes who pushed this nonsense it of
course was not true and then he lied to
the American people about what the Iran
deal would do and then he
helps ship pallets of cash to the
Iranian so they could use them for
terror the Obama administration openly
recognized that that cash was going to
be used for terrorism against Western
sources Ben Rhodes tweeted this said the
Iranian people are rightfully demanding
dignity less corruption more opportunity
and greater control over their lives in
looking at us Twitter it seems lost on
too many that this is about what
Iranians want for Ron and not about us
first of all ben rhoades
shut it dude if there's one guy who's
responsible for the rise of Iran in the
region Ben Rhodes is that guy but beyond
that if they're rightfully demanding
dignity less corruption more opportunity
and greater control might that have
something to do with them protesting the
same regime you just handed billions of
dollars the same regime you gave
regional power it's not just Ben Rhodes
John Kerry tweets out to John Kerry back
from the dead with his collapsing face
looks like a mudslide in the Sun
Fernando Hills it says with humility
about how little we know about what's
happening inside Iran this much is clear
it's an Iranian moment and not anyone
elses but the rights of people to
protest peacefully and voice their
aspirations are universal and
governments everywhere should respect
that he's so boring that when you even
read his tweets in John Kerry's voice he
starts to fall asleep and there are less
than 280 characters let's be clear about
something
when he says this is an Iranian moment
we should shut up when he says the
rights of people to protest peacefully
our universal governments should respect
that those are mutually exclusive
statements if it's if it's an Iranian
moment and we should shut up then we
should shut up about how Iran is putting
down the protesters but the point here
is that we shouldn't shut up Iran is
putting down the protesters who should
be siding with the protesters we should
be giving them as much covert aid as
possible because they're they are part
and parcel of bringing down possibly the
most evil regime on the planet the only
other possibilities for that title would
probably be North Korea and some of the
sub-saharan African regimes that have
led to slaughter of their own people but
the the notion that John Kerry is some
sort of voice of leadership here and all
of this is to say you know Susan Rice is
saying the same things for an op-ed from
the New York Times saying that everybody
should be quiet Trump should be quiet
we tried quiet in 2009 how'd it work out
for us how'd it work out for us not
the reason that so many people are
saying this is is twofold one they're
embarrassed by Obama's record on this
and they should be embarrassed by
Obama's record on this Obama's record on
this is embarrassing Obama's record on
Iran is embarrassing it is the great
blot on his presidency even more so than
Obama care his movement of Iran to his
central focus of the Middle East
demonstrates that his heart was not in
the right place when it came to them the
least and not only that there I truly
believe the Obama administration has
blood on its hands for handing billions
of dollars to a terror regime knowing
full well that the terror regime was
gonna use that to fund Hezbollah and
Hamas and Islamic Jihad and terrorist
groups around the world so there's the
the media are working full time to avoid
criticizing Obama because Obama of
course is their great God and he must
never be he must never be ripped or or
sneered at in any way now the other
thing is that there is this feeling
among a lot of the intelligentsia that
America is evil too
this is what I objected to when
President Trump during the campaign was
saying things as I mentioned before
about how the United States was like
Russia and we kill people too right that
spring from the sort of Ron Paul
isolationist wing of the Republican
Party I objected to it but that is a
mainstream thought on the left there are
a lot of people on the Left who believe
that America is a negative force in the
world Obama believed this he believed
that America had done terrible things
across the globe and that as America
shrunk her influence that somehow this
would make the world a better place
he believed that America was a
participant in domestic in domestic
evils that were on par with some of the
things that were happening abroad I
remember he gave a speech at the United
Nations and at the speech of the United
Nations he criticized America's policies
on policing I remember this because I
wrote about it I used to actually watch
all of his speeches and write them up
and there's a reason that the Iranian
government is jumping on that the
Iranian government loves the perspective
of the left on the United States the
American government believes that the
United States is an evil place
domestically and that America is is a
place filled with horror and awful and
evil and garbage they that's what they
believe so Ayatollah Khomeini who is the
the current Ayatollah he wrote the the
tweet of the South the US government
commits oppression inside the u.s. to
u.s. police murder black women men and
children for no justifiable reason the
murderers are acquitted in US courts
this is their judicial system and they
slam other countries in our
country's judicial system and so America
is hypocritical and terrible that's the
that's the line that come a knee is
using and he's not alone right
huffington post political commentator
named alex moja hair tweeted quote the
iranian protest the resistance and
women's march are all the same across
the world people are fighting
autocracies and oppressive regimes
president Trump is no different than the
oppressive ayatollahs in Iran you know
crazy you have to be to believe this but
this is a mainstream thought on the Left
I tweeted out in the middle of these
protests that you want to see true
courage look at the women who are
protesting a regime that will jail them
for taking off a hijab right those are
the people who are brave not the women
wearing hats in New York City
there's no risk to that to be brave you
actually have to undergo risk it is no
risk to protest on the streets of New
York or Los Angeles because this is a
free country but I'm not seeing the
women's March
I'm not seeing black lives matters have
one damn thing to say about what's going
on in Iran may black lives matter
doesn't have that agenda but the women's
March certainly should the women's March
is talking about women's rights want to
talk about a place with no women's
rights talk about Iran but apparently
they have nothing to say and how meny
knows it the far left in the United
States believes that America is a force
for evil in the world they always have
the far left and that's why America's
enemies have always used the far left is
they're useful idiots constantly they've
used the American far left is that
useful idiots I'll explain that in just
a second but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Bull and
branch so I hope that you got a lot of
sleep over the holiday but if you didn't
sleep as well as you'd like if you
didn't sleep as well as you think is
necessary then you need to go over to
Boleyn Branch because they just make the
great greatest shoots in the world do
you think that sheets don't matter you
go to the story you pick up whatever
sheets are on the shelf or you're
driving past a gas station in LA and it
says 1000 thread-count which doesn't
mean anything and you buy it and you go
home and you sleep on that tarp and it's
just terrible it's a tarp it's not good
instead you should be looking to my
friends over at pol and branch ok bull
and branch bol and branch calm they make
everything from bedding to blankets and
made from pure 100% organic cotton it
means they start out super soft they get
even softer over time the more you wash
them the better they get they are just
incredible I love my ball and bran
cheats I've I can't honestly sleep on
sheets that are not bowling branch
anymore they've ruined sleep for me
because they're so good right now
my listeners get $50 off your first set
of sheets at bull and branch calm promo
code Ben
bull and branch calm
promo Kabam they're a lot less expensive
than they would be if you tried to get
them retail because they're skipping the
middleman and going direct to you three
ex presidents and Bill Clinton's lovers
presumably sleep on bull and branch
sheets and they are spectacular bull and
branch combi o ll and branch com promo
code Benin when you use that you get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets again
once you get one Center Bowl and branch
sheet you're gonna want to get a few
more because they really are fantastic I
have them for my kids I have them for
the guests they are they are just
terrific okay so as I mentioned there's
a reason that the ayatollahs are pushing
the notion that America is a terrible
horrible no good very bad place right
the reason that they are pushing that
notion is because they have allies in
the United States who are happy also to
push that particular notion and those
allies are not just crazy columnist for
The Huffington Post right those allies
are places like the New York Times so
here is what the New York Times was
tweeting out in the middle of these
demonstrations quote Iranian authorities
have clamped down on Tehran after
demonstrators across the country ignored
calls for calm right so this is it this
is the real problem is that the
demonstrators ignored the calls for calm
it's not that there's a repressive
regime that will literally arrest or
shoot people who dissent the real
problem is that these people were just
ignoring calls for comments funny I
don't remember any of these sorts of
headlines with regard to the
Palestinians who literally assault
Israeli soldiers like walk up and slap
him in the face I remember any of this
and the Israeli government is not a
repressive government the Israeli
government is the only free government
the Middle East I remember any of these
headlines every time the Palestinians
throw rocks at an Israeli soldier
they're heroes every time and the
Israeli government's a democratic
government and the Palestinian
government is not every time Iranian
protesters stands up against an
oppressive regime the New York Times is
talking about how really they're just
ignoring the moderation of the Iranian
regime this article from The New York
Times is astonishing
right it's astonishing it demonstrates
the fundamental disconnect that the left
has with reality with regard to Iran
which again is reflective of both Obama
administration policy and more deeply of
the left's discontent with America's
role across the world and in the Middle
East
Thomas era brink is the author of this
New York Times piece and says he
reported then he reported that violence
broke out in Ron quote after
demonstrators ignored calls for calm by
president Hassan rouhani and then he
termed rouhani who is a tool of the
mullahs right no one gets elected
president of Iran unless the mullah say
okay
he calls him a moderate meanwhile 1 CNN
anchor fronted that President Trump
might quote put a finger on the scale
against the Iranian regime right this is
what the CNN was was deeply worried
about that again the New York Times
piece is is really amazing I'm gonna try
and find a couple of excerpts from the
New York Times because it really is that
garbage a the let's see here here's what
the New York Times had to say but they
said is quote despite mr. rouhani's
diplomatic language it was clear the
demonstrators would be given no leeway
mr. rouhani has urged demonstrators to
avoid violence but defended the right to
protest he did so again on Monday on
Twitter yes I am sure that rouhani is
speaking absolutely objectively and
honestly that he believes in their right
to protest and won't arrest them or
shoot them at all 15 people are dead in
protest can you you need to that sounds
like not a big number imagine if in one
weekend there are protests in the United
States against President Trump and 15 of
the protesters will end up being shot by
the cops imagine that for half a second
you understand how crazy that would be
do you understand how evil that would be
do you understand how we'd all go nuts
and yet we just accept that the Iranian
regime is supposed to be moderate
because the New York Times says so right
here is their their rationale rouhani by
the way is a Holocaust denier he's a
radical just as much as anyone according
to the New York Times here's why these
protests are happening quote this time
it is the failure of president rouhani a
moderate to deliver greater political
changes an economic opportunity
despite the lifting of some of the
sanctions against Iran as part of the
nuclear deal young people are especially
angry the average age of those arrested
is under 25 one official said and here's
what they add many youths in larger
cities enthusiastically voted for mr.
rouhani when he was reelected in May
raising expectations among many in the
reform camp but since then even many of
the president's supporters say he has
failed to fulfill his promises for
improving an economy sorely hobbled by
years of sanctions corruption and
mismanagement beyond that the United
States has continued other sanctions
making it still harder for mr. rouhani
to make gains see it's Trump's fault
don't you understand the reason their
protests in Iran is because Trump is
mean to rouhani and then rouhani doesn't
have the money to pay off the youngsters
that's the reason if you believe that
you have to be stupid enough to be a
member of the media to really believe
that it's just astonishing it's just
astonishing and terrible but not a shock
at all here's a CNN
correspondent right again this just
demonstrates that when the left thinks
more leadership they think the Europeans
ought to be exhibiting it and American
presidents ought to be taking a back
seat
this is Arwa Damon who is a senior
international correspondent for CNN and
she talks about how America doesn't have
any moral leg to stand on
a lot of nations and their populations
no matter how they feel about their
governments in particular do perceive
the United States as not really having a
moral leg to stand on they don't
perceive us as having more like the
Stannah the Iranian government literally
hangs gay people from cranes and we
don't have a moral leg to stand on and
CNN is repeating that sort of nonsense
and the fact is the people in places
like Arash in Iran they require our help
and I hope that President Trump has
authorized all covert help to topple
this regime it would be a massive
benefit to the world honestly I didn't
think we would see a repeat of 2009 in
my lifetime I could not be more pleased
that within ten years we are seeing
another huge movement against the
ayatollahs now that is a great thing and
I hope that the Trump administration
continues to do what it's doing
the media's defense for Obama on this is
just astonishing and it's really gross
and there's really no excuse for but
speaking of media bias so the New York
Times has now released a story in an
attempt to quash all of the talk about
the the Russia dossier the New York
Times has released a new story so this
was the the big news story last week but
we didn't have a chance to discuss so if
you will recall all the way back to last
year I know it feels like forever ago if
I recall all the way back to last year
there was a the the narrative was
basically now that the Moller
investigation had originally been
launched the FBI investigations Trump
Russia collusion had originally been
launched based on the dossier the
so-called Russian dossier now Russian da
CA had been paid for by fusion GPS
fusion GPS had been funded by Democrats
they dug up a bunch of supposed dirt
about Trump and then the FBI had jumped
on that dossier to get a bunch of FISA
warrants and go after members of the
Trump team a lot of people including me
had said that if that was true if that
was really why FBI had launched its
investigation based on this dossier then
that called into question the entirety
of the investigation if based on a
Democrat funded Apple research project
that had not been
substantiate in any real way they've
they've started this entire effort and
it looks like a lot of smoke and no fire
so the New York Times came out with an
article over the break and that article
basically tried to kill that narrative
so the article essentially suggested
that the reason the FBI originally
launched its investigation is because
there it was a guy as you remember his
name was Papadopoulos right his name was
George papadopolis and George
papadopolis was a was a foreign policy
adviser to the Trump administration and
the idea was that George papadopolis had
basically gone around telling people
that the Russian government had hacked
Hillary's servers or at hacked the DNC
and that he and had been giving material
to the Trump administration or to the
Trump campaign and based on that there
the FBI had found out about this and
then launched an investigation into
collusion between Trump and Russia so it
had nothing to do with the dossier at
all the dossier is a backburner issue
this is the this is what the New York
Times reported number one I'm not sure
how much to trust the story because
again it is based on anonymous sourcing
and and whenever you have an anonymous
lease or a story like this it's very
difficult to trust it all the way second
of all even if it was based on
Papadopoulos going around and saying
things that doesn't necessarily mean
that the actual investigation came up
with anything or that it wasn't biased
and how it pursued the investigation
right if they then went ahead and used
the dossier in any way then that calls
into question bias in the investigation
the fact that Peter straws ik who was as
you recall a high-ranking lawyer who was
working with the FBI and the DOJ in
their pursuit of Trump Russia collusion
that he was an anti-trump crusader and
that he was having an affair with
another member of the team and that they
had suggested that there was an
insurance policy against Trump should
Trump win the presidency and all of that
does continues to call into question the
Muller investigation as a whole however
I wanted to report that to you so at
least you have the full information
David French has a very good piece about
this
so does Andrew McCarthy over at National
Review and and he points out does does
Andrea McCarthy that The Times collusion
narrative the The Times story about
Trump Russia collusion seems to be a lot
of garbage for the most part that the
the
for this entire investigation was not
actually Papadopoulos it was actually
Carter page you remember the Carter page
was the guy who originally they got the
FISA warrant against and that deepened
into a full-scale investigation because
Carter page traveled to Moscow again a
lot of smoke no fire not much here
here's what we do know right this is
another astonishing story that broke
over the weekend Hillary Clinton
supported David Brock's American Bridge
21st century foundation that's according
to the New York Times again gave
attorney Lisa blooms firm $200,000 to
help support a sexual misconduct case
against Donald Trump according to the
New York Times sources were described as
two Democrats familiar with the
arrangements they also said that a
fashion designer named Suzy Tompkins
Buell gave $500,000 for the same purpose
the sources claimed that Blum returned
money to Buell but kept the cash from
Brock Blum that is according Mediaite
Blum declined to name the donors when
The Times reached out for comment she
said the donors reached out to her and
asked how they could help she told them
that she was working with several women
who could find the courage to speak out
if funds were given for security and the
like even a safe house woman woman one
woman wanted two million dollars and
declined to talk hey this is pretty
dirty stuff you're gonna talk about
dirty campaigning dirty campaigning
involves partisan people funding sexual
assault allegations against a particular
candidate okay like I understand that
it's risky business for women to come
forward and claim sexual assault but it
does cast a lot of doubt on your account
if you are being paid by the opposition
if you're in paid by Hillary Clinton's
camp and then you're making allegations
against Donald Trump it does raise some
serious questions about the nature of
the allegations that you are putting
forth so that's that is that is not good
for the entire narrative that the only
person who is cheating in the election
the person who was really manipulating
the election was that was president
Trump okay before I go any further I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at zip recruiter so it is a fresh
new year and you need employees you need
the best employees you need the best
employees you can find the way that you
get those employees is you go over to
zip recruiter zip recruiter post your
job to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards with just one click then zip
recruiter actively looks for the most
qualified candidates and invites them to
apply they even review every application
to identify the top candidates so you
never miss a great match that is why zip
recruiter is different unlike other
hiring sites zip recruiter does not
depend on the right candidates finding
you it finds them instead it's no wonder
that 80
of employers who post on zip recruiter
to get a quality candidate through the
site in just one day you have to go to
zip recruiter it's the smartest way to
hire and right now by the way my
listeners can post unzip recruiter at
for free that is right free go to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that is
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire one
more time go to zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire and you can post jobs for
free which again you're gonna get the
best employees you don't have to worry
about your inbox being filled up because
it all runs through their websites you
can accept it it's miss an employee
really quickly zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire to check it out okay so I
want to talk for a second about Logan
Paul so Logan Paul is this YouTube star
you've probably never heard of him but
you put your kids probably have he has a
just a ton of social media following
some like nine point four million
followers on YouTube and again he's one
of these folks who I have no idea who he
is because well I am technically a
millennial I'm at the upper bracket of
millennial I'm not close enough to
millennial age to really understand why
a guy running around being weird is is
worth watching particularly but Logan
Paul decided that he was going to
Japan's so-called suicide forest near
Mount Fuji they've made a movie about
the suicide forest recently and remember
who is in it was a Christian Bale I mean
there was a movie about this recently
this forest is very famous because
apparently a lot of people go here to
commit suicide something like a hundred
people have committed suicide in the
past few years in this forest so it's
super creepy and terrible so he this guy
goes there Logan Paul I'm not sure what
he expected to find I guess he was gonna
try and do a Blair Witch Project type of
thing like go camping in the forest and
then it was gonna be creepy and
everybody's gonna laugh and that was
gonna be it well he went into the forest
and instead what he actually found is
within um basically minutes of walking
into the forest he found a guy hanging
from a tree he found somebody who'd
hanged himself and we're not gonna show
much of the video because now been
pulled down but Logan Paul walks in
wearing you know the green aliens hat
really from he's actually from Toy Story
and and then he stumbles on this dead
body
and they shoot the dead body I mean they
they like shooting on camera for minutes
at a time and basically end up joking
about it it's just really gross you
think that's real
a classmate in the junior high school he
really killed himself no how long do you
how long ago do you think you did
okay so they actually show the guy
hanging from the tree and then they keep
showing the guy hanging from the tree
it's like a ten minute video so Logan
pop pulled down the video because he got
a lot of flack for it as well he should
making light of this there's no reason
why you would show video of suicide
suicide particularly is an imitative act
in many cases there have been a lot of
high profile suicides and the data show
that after high profile suicides there's
actually a wave of suicide that happens
because people think well if that person
can do it then so can i this is a really
bad move by logan paul he got a lot of
flack what i won't discuss her is not
the bad move by logan paul because i
think that's obvious and everybody
understands it what I want to discuss
here instead is the fact that the entire
media internet went crazy even after he
pulled it down so the guy pulls down the
video when people continue to lose their
minds over to the extent that they were
calling for the entirety monetization of
his YouTube channel I think that's a
massive massive mistake there are these
social media pylons that now happen that
I think are not good for the country or
for the world I think that there should
be enough blowback to people like logan
paul pulled down their stupidity and
there is social media upset i think
that's relevant but the idea that you're
going to destroy the guy's entire life
or entire career for posting a bad video
i think is is foolish and i think what
it really mostly has to do with is it's
a low cost high reward way of making
clear that you are a moral person is to
find something that is obviously
terrible like showing dead bodies on a
YouTube video and turning it into kind
of joke you know that's obviously
terrible and it's a way to for you to
turn that into I'm a bit I'm a good
person I'm a better person we all
understand it's terrible okay and this
is not about taking suicide anything but
deeply seriously my grandfather suffered
from suicidality he tried to commit
suicide at least once that I know about
and there are other members of my family
who've had this problem the idea that
that logan paul is doing anything worthy
here is ridiculous he is not but there
is this tendency now that when something
goes wrong and we can all condemn it
like 100 percent of people condemn it
and now we have to rip down the person's
career or destroy their entire life over
it even after they do the right thing he
pulled this thing down within like 24
hours he apologized for it he'll
probably end up giving a bunch of money
to a suicide charity i'm not sure what
more you want from the guy other than
take him for what he is which is kind of
a dolt i think maybe
people have clear vision of what the guy
is he's kind of an idiot but I object to
you know it's easy to talk about what I
object to in the video which is quite
terrible but I think I'd rather talk
about what I object to in the social
media age which is this idea that if
somebody like a justine sacco right
tweets something yucky about about how
she's flying to Africa and people in
Africa have AIDS then by the time she
lands her plane she's been fired and her
career has been destroyed I think that's
that's making for a very nasty social
environment that doesn't actually that
doesn't actually make the world better
even though you're trying to shut down
stupidities like this video okay so I
have a lot more to talk about things I
like things I hate the Federalist paper
today because we didn't have show on
Monday but before we do any of that
first you have to go over to Daley wire
comso for daily wire comude become a
subscriber $9.99 a month gets you that
subscription and it is phenomenal you
get the rest of my show live on video
you get the rest of Michael Knowles's
show live on video it's a brand new year
get yourself a treat make a new year's
resolution to get yourself a daily wire
subscription and when you get that not
that annual subscription for ninety nine
dollars a year you get this be very
greatest in the leftist tiers hot or
cold tumbler so fantastic so grand so
great you will enjoy every day this year
and it will be a year of many leftist
years I have a feeling they are coming
in on a daily basis so if your other mug
has already overflowed then buy a
subscription for one of your friends and
then steal this particular tumbler and
use it as a second to overflow mug in
any case you can get that for your
annual subscription also you get to ask
us questions and the mailbag on Friday
and be part of the show more broadly the
Shapiro storm will be launching at
sometime this year
no really like we're in a new year I
promise it's happening I think we are
only weeks away of course I've been
saying that for months but it will
happen and you will get discounts so get
all of that or go over download the show
SoundCloud
iTunes Google Play stitcher any of the
apps that the download podcast we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
okay time for some things I like and
then we'll do some things that I hate so
now things that I like let's begin with
the Sam Harris debate so as I said late
last year I think it was late to some or
early December I did a debate with Sam
Harris who is who does his own podcast
called waking up with Sam Harris I and
Eric Weinstein who's become a friend
he's also the CEO for up for Peter Thiel
and and we all did a debate slash
discussion about religion and free
speech and atheism and the meaning of
life and morality and it was really
great we did this big event up in San
Francisco Sam has a great audience and
great crowd probably 2,500 people 3,000
people showed up and it was just a lot
of fun it's now up you can go listen to
it over at sam Harris's website you can
also download it I believe from Sam
Harris's podcast so check that out
that's well worth listening to
also this week tomorrow we're gonna be
doing Dave Rubens show so you should
take a look at that because I'm gonna
livestream that as well so I'll be on
Dave Rubin also I believe I'm on Jordan
Peterson show this week so I'll be
making the rounds in the new year so
that's really exciting but this was a
really fun discussion and it gets to
some really root issues about religion
and belief and meaning and free will and
determinism and choice it was really
quite fascinating I enjoyed it quite a
lot
Sam's a really good guy and we may
disagree on some of the most fundamental
issues of the universe but there are
certain things we definitely do not
disagree on and that is the value of
discussion and the value of free speech
so go check that out okay other things
that I like so I have become a big fan
of this show on Netflix called the last
Kingdom so if you're on sort of Game of
Thrones hiatus and you're looking for
something to watch this is basically
Game of Thrones without the mantric and
without the it's got some sex scenes but
they are kind of parodic and in how
they're done in then in case it's really
a good show I like it a lot the show is
about the birth of England in the 9th
century it's all about how England was
unified into one country because it used
to be a bunch of separate kingdoms
basically and it follows this guy who
thread who is basically a saxon kid who
is kidnapped by the danes and raised as
a Dane and so he's sort of half day and
half Saxon if you don't know anything
about British history it's really
fascinating the Vikings were a large
part of British history they basically
invaded the island of Britain very very
early on and they were fighting with the
Saxons and then
you'd have the later you would have the
normans who are coming over from France
it's all really interesting stuff in any
case check it out the last Kingdom it's
it's well worth watching here's a little
bit of the preview ships I saw the first
from the beach what ships things we were
Kings here once boy our ancestors took
this land and it has been strengthened
with our blood and bone
now you are the new heir of Bella ba and
you will die for it if needed
yes Father what kind of hell is this
so the battle scenes are actually really
cool it shows how the Danes use
particular strategies and if you like
the if you like the battle the bastards
episode from from Game of Thrones
there's a lot of that kind of stuff in
the show so it's it's really fun and
worth watching okay one more thing that
I like so as you recall we made fun of
it on the show
clay Travis was on CNN last year one of
my favorite media moments in all the
last year clay Travis is on CNN with
Brooke Baldwin and he was talking with
her and suddenly he just launches into a
random monologue about how his two
favorite things or boobs in the First
Amendment should have said his three
favorite things were boobs in the First
Amendment and she acted all offended and
it was just terrible
how dare so there was a couple who
decided to fake a wedding proposal and
to mock CNN so watch this they just
shout Clay Travis and Clay Travis is
slogan pretty spectacular Scott what's
your name my name is Dustin Dustin we
understand you have something special
[Music]
I love you
wait for it wait for it guys the entire
thing was a prank so that you could
shout into the microphone on CNN I love
boobs be double OBS
well done Clay Travis fan well done and
that's exactly what CNN deserves because
I'm gonna show you in my things I hate
in just a second some things about CNN
that um yeah so things I hate so CNN is
a network you'll remember was filled
with such umbrage right they they were
they're propriety was insulted by Clay
Travis saying boobs in the First
Amendment here's what they do on New
Year's Eve on New Year's Eve they just
make a mockery of themselves so they
send down Brooke Baldwin to New Orleans
right a place for boobs in the First
Amendment right it's basically Clay
Travis's frat house and and there you
have people like Brooke Baldwin right
who is very offended as you'll recall
SuperDuper offended by that language how
dare you say B oo EE double OBS how dare
you say that on national TV
here is where she tells Don Lemon about
the size of her testicles yeah really
[Music]
and then they all danced on CNN because
this is the the most trusted name in
news get that James Earl Jones voice
going over there
okay that wasn't the only ridiculous
moment from New Year's Eve also they
decided to legitimately do drugs on the
air on CNN so that was exciting as clip
eight so this is CNN had a had a
reporter who legitimately started
smoking weed on air on New Year's Eve
in Denver how's it going Randy its it
it's going great
I'm definitely earning the nickname cush
k that's for sure so listen uh I came
prepared you know this year I thought
maybe I would bring a gas mask with me
so I wouldn't you know get that contact
high the other end of the gas mask yes a
bong and of course they couldn't stand
to see a bong that didn't have any
cannabis in it so you actually put it in
the bong you filled it up yeah and you
don't want it you don't want it to be
back you packing okay okay so you're
gonna now what now you're gonna
celebrate a little new years earlier was
with you oh right okay this I don't
think this is really what a gas mask is
used for but Wow
and everybody's just gonna do pot right
there on the air and there's Anderson
Cooper just grinning along now look at
that nusiness look at that nusiness why
don't we trust them why do we call them
fake news I don't know I can't imagine
how could such a thing happen that is
crazy
and.and why would we call them fake news
when over the break they do things like
this okay here is CNN complaining that
they can't cover Trump golfing so you
know they're covering all the important
things by the way CNN's coverage on Iran
has been really garbage you over the
last few days as I showed you see a none
commentator saying that America has no
moral authority they went crazy because
over the break President Trump went
golfing you know like over Christmas
break
like most presidents do and a white
truck so CNN tried to get tape of Trump
golfing because it's we desperately
needed to know what Trump looks like
when he golf's like I'm sorry I really
don't care I didn't care what Obama
golfed I don't care when Trump golf's as
far as what a what they look like or how
good they were who cares CNN went crazy
because the Trump team hired a
white truck to basically roll alongside
CNN camera crew and prevent them from
shooting into the golf course and they
went nuts over on CNN about it the
president president doesn't really and
his staff doesn't really tell us when he
is golfing and we have taken to you know
going outside the golf course and
filming him as he golfs through a break
in hedges near the club today a big wha
a white box truck parked in front of
those hedges trying to obscure our shot
of President Trump golf II now this may
seem trivial but it is important to get
video of the president as he does these
things on a daily basis and it gets to
something that is larger the president
and the White House have tried to
obscure the fact that President Trump
golf's on a regular basis what know what
what the like yes and yes clearly you
guys are covering the news that matters
it's deeply important that you see Trump
swing the swing the club that's that's
deeply important and how dare that truck
so people started making memes of the of
the white truck pulling in front of the
Iranian protests so that CNN would have
an excuse not to cover there any tests
and I think that that is basically
correct okay final stuff that I hate so
president Trump I spends a lot of the
show praising him over what he has done
with Iran I think that he is correct on
this I'd like to see more aid being sent
to the protesters in Iran whatever can
be done should be done for those
protesters but it is the first day of
the new year and that means that we have
to do some good Trump bad Trump so let's
do it
[Music]
all righty so there we are brand-new
year thanks to Brandon Snipes of course
the creator of that theme so we had some
good Trump earlier bad Trump so
President Trump took to Twitter this
morning and I don't like when Trump
tweets stupid things in the middle of a
serious news cycle because it allows the
media the excuse to distract from the
actual news which is what's going on in
Iran which is what they should be forced
to cover like Trump should be using his
Twitter his Twitter machine as a
battering ram he should be clubbing the
media with it instead from tweets out
stuff like this so here's what Trump
tweeted out there were zero commercial
aviation deaths this year here's what
Trump tweeted out since taking office
I've been very strict and commercial
aviation good news
it was just reported there were zero
capital Z deaths in 2017 the best and
safest year unrecorded
yes I am sure mr. president you're
responsible for the planes not falling
from the sky I'm sure that was you just
for the record there have been zero
commercial aviation deaths in the United
States since 2008 okay so it's it's it's
been a pretty good run for commercial
aviation I really don't think that it's
Trump hanging out at air traffic control
directing the planes visit this is on
par with Al Gore saying he invented the
internet and as long as we're gonna try
this strategy I'm gonna take credit for
our house being cleaned today I'm not
gonna do any the cleaning and probably
will get cleaned not by me but I'll take
credit for it because hey it's my house
just absurd that was not the only absurd
tweet of the day president from trying
out a little bit of game theory he
tweets about dacow so daca as you'll
recall is the deferred action for
childhood arrivals program he had he had
struck down Obama's executive order on
that and then thrown it to Congress and
then he said at the time that if
Congress if Congress didn't acts then
maybe he'd replace it put it back in
place in March so here's what he tweeted
Democrats are doing nothing for daca
just interested in politics daca
activists in Hispanics will go hard
against tens will start falling in love
with Republicans in their president we
are about results all capital results
here is the problem with this particular
statement so what this is basically
saying is that if the Democrats don't
make a deal on the deferred action for
childhood arrivals programs they don't
give him his wall or if they don't give
him his his increased immigration
funding or his or his crackdowns on some
illegal immigration then President Trump
will just put daca back in place and
then presumably Hispanics will be super
happy with him that's not a bar
strategy and it doesn't even make any
sense all right if you're gonna bargain
you actually have to take a hard
position I'm not sure by what math
Hispanics are gonna go hard against the
Democrats or pushing for a pure daca and
fall for President Trump and fall in
love with Republicans and their
president unless presumably Trump were
to basically throw over his base and
just replace daca with new daca trump
daca trump akka I I don't think that
that's going to happen maybe it will but
I don't know what the hell he's talking
about here so that's that's not good
Trump okay finally it is a Tuesday
normally we deconstruct some culture but
we're gonna do a federalist paper
instead every week on Mondays we do a
federalist paper we'll go through this
one really quickly because we're already
running over time but hey it's the first
show of the year we have to ruin
everything so Federalist number nine is
Federalist paper number nine written by
Alexander Hamilton so this one Hamilton
is continuing his discussion on how a
national government is going to be
stronger than several governments in the
United States that are not under the
rubric of one United government you know
just the country of South Carolina for
example so critics says Hamilton
condemned republicanism is unstable and
he points out from the disorders that
disfigure the annals of those Republic's
the advocates of despotism have drawn
arguments not only against the forms of
republican government but against the
very principles of civil liberty they
have decried all free government's as
inconsistent with the order of society
and have indulged themselves in
malicious exultation over its friends
and partisans first of all if Hamilton's
a beautiful writer but second of all
what he is saying here is he is saying
that a lot of people who say that
monarchy despotism is better than
democracy because democracy devolves
into anarchy and this would be the sort
of the Thomas Hobbes argument Leviathan
this Hamilton says is wrong because
there are many different types of
democracy and equate in all of them
is foolish like there there's messy
democracy and then there's well-ordered
Republican checks and balances and
that's what Hamilton is making the
argument for he says we've basically
designed a new design a new form of
government which includes modern
inventions like checks and balances and
institutions of courts composed of
judges holding their offices during good
behavior and he says that this is also
going to one of the checks against an
overpowering central government here is
going to be the states the states are
going to be their own Republic's and
they will have their own localities and
so the devolution of authority down to
lower and lower levels is going to lead
to checks and balances that prevent the
irrigation of all authority in a
centralized figure and also prevent the
decay into
Archy so hamilton quotes a philosopher
named Montesquieu if you studied this in
high school at all you'll know
Montesquieu was a French philosopher who
died I believe 1755 and he was very
instrumental in formulating a lot of the
early ideas about legislative checks and
balances he really created that idea he
was in favor of basically a three branch
government you'll remember this
legislative executive judicial just like
the United States and and Montesquieu
had said a republic of this kind right
with checks and balances able to
withstand an external force may support
itself without any internal corruptions
the form of this society prevents all
manner of inconveniences if a single
member should attempt to usurp the
supreme authority he could not be
supposed to have an equal authority and
credit in all the Confederate states so
States will be a check on the federal
government where he to have too great an
influence over one this would alarm the
rest so if there were to be one state
that make alliance with another state
other states would oppose that so the
basic idea here is checks and balances
this is Hamilton making the affirmative
argument for it in Federalist number
nine as always Hamilton is a is a well
argued an articulate spokesperson for
this position okay we will be back here
tomorrow with all the latest news
welcome back
Happy New Year and we'll be here with
you all year long looking forward to be
big year midterm elections coming up so
what's happening I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike or Mina hair and makeup is by Jo
opera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2017